PROFESSOR: So welcome, everyone.
Today is the first
of what will be
a series of four guest lectures
throughout the semester.
There will be two
guest lectures,
starting the week from
today, and then there'll
be another one towards
the end of the semester.
And what Pete and
I decided to do
is to bring in people who
know a lot more than us
about some area of expertise.
In today's instance,
it's going to be
about cardiovascular
medicine, in particular
about how to use imaging
and machine learning
on images in that context.
And for today's
lecture, we're very
excited to have professor
Rahul Deo to speak.
Rahul's name kept on showing
up, as I did research
over the last couple of years.
First, my group was
starting to get interested
in echocardiography,
and we said, oh, here's
an interesting
paper to read on it.
We read it, and then
we read another paper
on doing subtyping
of ejection fraction
which is a type of heart
failure, and we read it.
I wasn't really paying attention
to the names on the papers,
and then suddenly,
someone told me,
there's this guy moving
to Boston next month who's
doing a lot of interesting
work and interesting machine
learning.
You should go meet him.
And of course, I
meet him, and then
I tell him about
these papers I read,
and he said, oh, I wrote
all of those papers.
He was a senior author on them.
So Rahul's been
around for a while.
He is already a
senior in his field.
He started out doing his medical
school training at Cornell,
in Cornell Medical
School, in New York
City, at the same time as
doing his PhD at Rockefeller
University.
And then he spent the
first large chunk--
after his post-doctoral
training, up here in Boston,
at Harvard Medical
School-- he spent
a large chunk of his career as
faculty at UCSF, in California.
And just moved back this
past year to take a position
as the chief data
scientist-- is that right--
for the One Brave
Idea project which
is a very large initiative
joint between MIT and Brigham
and Women's Hospital to study
cardiovascular medicine.
He'll tell you more maybe.
And Rahul's research has
really gone the full spectrum,
but the type of things
you'll hear about today
is actually not what he's
been doing most of his career,
amazingly so.
Most of his career,
he's been thinking more
about genotype and
how to really bridge
that genotype-phenotype branch,
but I asked him specifically
to talk about imaging.
So that's what he'll be focusing
on today in his lecture.
And without further ado, thank
you, Rahul, for coming here.
[APPLAUSE]
RAHUL DEO: So I'm
used to lecturing
the clinical audiences,
so you guys are by far
the most technical audience.
So please spare me a
little bit, but I actually
want to encourage
interruptions, questions.
This is a very
opinionated lecture,
so that if anybody has sort of
any questions, reservations,
please bring them
up during lecture.
Don't wait till the end.
And in part, it's opinionated
because I feel passionately
that the stuff we're doing needs
to make its way into practice.
It's not by itself purely
academically interesting.
We need to study the
things we're doing.
We're already picking up
what everybody else here
is already doing.
So it's OK from that
standpoint, but it really
has to make its way.
And that means that we have to
have some mature understanding
of what makes its
way into practice,
where the resistance will be.
So the lecture will be peppered
throughout with some opinions
and comments in that, and
hopefully, that will be useful.
So just a quick
outline, just going
to introduce cardiac structure
and function which is probably
not part of the regular
undergraduate and graduate
training here at MIT.
Talk a little bit about what the
major cardiac diagnostics are
and how they use them.
And all this is really
to help guide the thought
and the decision making
about how we would ever
automate and bring this into--
how to bring machine learning,
artificial intelligence,
into actual clinical practice.
Because I need to
give enough background
so you realize what
the challenges are,
and then the question probably
every has is where's the data?
How would how would
one get access
to some of this stuff to
be able to potentially do
work in this area?
And then, I'm going to venture a
little bit into computer vision
and just talk about
some of the topics
that at least I've been
thinking about that are
relevant to what we're doing.
And then talk about
some of this work
around an automated pipeline for
echocardiogram, not as by any
means a gold standard
but really just
as sort of an initial
foray into trying
to make a dent into this.
And then thinking a little
bit about what lessons--
David mentioned that you
talked about electrocardiogram
last week or last class,
and so a little bit of some
of the ideas from there, and
how they would lend themselves
to insights about future
types of approaches
with automated interpretation.
And then my background is
actually more in biology.
So I'm going to come
back and say, OK,
enough with all this imaging
stuff, what about the biology?
How can we make
some insights there?
OK.
So every time people
try to get funding
for coronary heart disease,
they try to talk up
just how important it is.
So this is still--
we have some battles with
the oncology people--
but this is still the leading
cause of death in the world.
And then people like I,
you're just emphasizing
the developed world.
There's lots of communicable
diseases that matter much more.
So even if you look at those,
and you look at the bottom
here, this still, if this is all
causes of death age-adjusted,
cardiovascular disease is
still number one amongst that.
So certainly it remains
important and increasingly so
in some of the
developing world also.
So it's important to think
a little bit about what
the heart does,
because this is going
to guide at least the way that
diseases have been classified.
So the main thing the
heart does is it's a pump,
and it delivers oxygenated
blood throughout the circulatory
system to all the
tissues that need it--
the brain, the kidneys, the
muscles, and oxygen, of course,
is required for ATP production.
So it's a pretty
impressive organ.
It pumps about five
liters of blood a minute,
and with exercise, that can go
up five to seven-fold or so,
with conditioned athletes,
not me, but other people
can ramp that up substantially.
And we have this need to keep
a very, very regular beat,
so if you pause for
about three seconds,
you are likely to get
lightheaded or pass out.
So you have to maintain this
rhythmic beating of your heart,
and you can compute
what that would be,
and somewhere around two billion
beats in a typical lifetime.
So I'm going to show a
lot of pictures and videos
throughout this.
So it's probably worthwhile just
to take a pause a little bit
and talk about what the
anatomy of the heart is.
So the heart sits like
this, so the pointy part
is kind of sitting out
to the side, like that.
And so I'm going to just sort
of describe the flow of blood.
So the blood comes in something
called the inferior vena
cava or the superior vena cava,
that's draining from the brain.
This is draining
from the lower body,
and then enters into a chamber
called the right atrium.
It moves through something
called the tricuspid valve
into what's called
the right ventricle.
The right ventricle has
got some muscle to it.
It pumps into the lungs.
There, the blood
picks up oxygen,
so that's why it's
shown as being red here.
The oxygenated native blood
comes through the left atrium
and then into the left
ventricle through something
called the mitral valve.
We'll show you some pictures
of the mitral valve later on.
And then the left
ventricle, which
is the big workhorse
of the heart,
pumps blood through
the rest of the body,
through a structure
of the aorta.
So in through the right
heart, through the lungs,
through the left heart,
to the rest of the body.
And then shown here in yellow
is the conduction system.
So you guys got a little bit
of a conversation last class
on the electrical system.
So the sinoatrial node is
up here in the right atrium,
and then conduction
goes through.
So the P wave on an EKG
represents the conduction
through there.
You get through
the AV node, where
there's a delay which
is a PR interval,
and then you get spreading
through the ventricles which
is the QRS complex, and then
repolarization is the T wave.
So that's the electrical system,
and of course, these things
have to work
intimately together.
Every single basic kind
of cardiac physiology
will show this diagram called
the Wiggers diagram which
really just shows the
interconnectedness
of the electrical system.
So there's the EKG up there.
These are the heart sounds
that a provider would listen to
with the stethoscope,
and this is
capturing the flow of sort
of the changes in pressure
in the heart and in the aorta.
So heart fills during a period
of time called diastole.
The mitral valve closes.
The ventricle contracts.
The pressure increases.
This is a period of
time called systole.
Eventually, something called
the aortic valve pops open,
and blood goes through
the rest of the body.
The heart finally
starts to relax.
The atrioventricular
valve closes.
Then, you fill again.
So this happens again and again
and again in a cyclical way,
and you have this combination
of electrical and mechanical
properties.
OK.
So I have some pictures here.
These are all MRIs.
I'm going to talk about
echocardiography which
is these very ugly, grainy
things that I unfortunately
have to work with.
MRIs are beautiful
but very expensive.
So there's a reason for that.
So this is something called the
long axis view of the heart.
So this is the thick walled
left ventricle there.
This is the left
atrium there, and you
can see this beautiful turbulent
flow of blood in there,
and it's flowing from the
atrium to the ventricle.
This is another patient's.
It's called the short axis view.
There is the left ventricle
and the right ventricle there.
So we're kind of looking
at it somewhat obliquely,
and then this is another
view called the physical.
It's a little bit dull there.
I'm sorry.
We can brighten it a little bit.
This is the what's called
the four chamber view.
So you can see the left
ventricle and right ventricle
here.
So the reason for
these different views
is, ultimately, that
people have measures
of function and measures
of disease that go along
with these specific views.
So you're going to see them
coming back again and again.
OK.
So the way that physicians like
to organize disease definitions
really around some of these
same kind of functions.
So failures of the
heart to pump properly
causes a disease
called heart failure,
and this shows up in terms of
being out of breath, having
fluid buildup in the
belly and in the legs,
and this is treated
with medications.
Sometimes, you can have
some artificial devices
to help the heart pump,
and ultimately, you
could even have a transplant,
depending on how severe it is.
So that's the pump.
Blood supply to the heart
ultimately can also be blocked,
and that causes a disease
called coronary artery disease.
If blood is completely
blocked, you
can get something called a
heart attack or myocardial
infarction.
That's chest pain, sometimes
shortness of breath,
and we open up those blocked
vessels by angioplasty,
stick a stent in there,
or bypass them altogether.
And then the flow of
blood has to be one way.
So abnormalities of flow
of the blood through valves
is valvular disease, and so
you can have either two type
valves, so that's
called stenosis.
Or you can have leaky valves.
That's called regurgitation.
That shows up as
light-headedness, shortness
of breath, fainting, and then
you've got to fix those valves.
And finally, there's
abnormalities of rhythm.
So something like
atrial fibrillation
which is a quivering of the
atrium, so too slow heartbeats,
which would look like cardiac,
can present as palpitations,
fainting, or even sudden death.
And you can stick a pacemaker in
there, defibrillator in there,
or try to burn off
the arrhythmia.
OK.
So this is like the very
physiology-centric view,
but the truth is that the
heart has a whole lot of cells.
So there's a lot more
biology there than simply
just thinking about the pumping
and the electrical function.
Only 30% of the cells or so
are these cardiomyocytes.
So these are the cells that
are involved in contraction.
These are cells that are
excitable, but that's only 30%
of the cells.
There is endothelials
in the cell.
There's fibroblasts.
There's a bunch of
blood cells in there
too, certainly a lot of red
blood cells in there too.
So you have lots
of other things.
So we're going to come
back to here a little bit
when talking about how should
we be thinking about disease?
The historic way is
to think about pumping
and electrical activation,
but really, there's
maybe a little bit
more complexity here
that needs to be addressed.
OK.
So there's a lot of different--
so cardiology is
very imaging-centric,
and as a result,
it's very expensive.
Because imaging costs
a lot of money to do,
and so I have dollar
signs here reflecting
the sorts of
different tests we do.
So you saw the
cheapest one last week,
electrocardiogram,
so one dollar sign,
and that has lots of utility.
For example, one could
diagnose an acute heart attack
with that.
Echocardiography, which
involves sound waves,
is ultimately more used
for quantifying structure
and function, can pick up heart
failure, valvular disease,
high blood pressure
in the lungs.
So that's another modality.
MRI, which is just not used
all that much in this country,
is very expensive.
It does largely the same
things, and you can imagine,
even though it's
beautiful, people
have not had an easy
time and able to justify
why it's any better than this
slightly cheaper modality.
And then you have angiography
which can either be by CAT scan
or by X-ray.
And that visualizes the flow
of blood through the heart
and looks for blockages which
are going to be stented,
ballooned up and stented.
And then you had these kind
of non-invasive technologies,
like PET and SPECT that
use radionucleotides,
like technetium,
rubidium, and they
look for abnormalities
in blood flow
to detect whether
or non-invasively
there's some patch
of the heart that
isn't getting enough blood.
If you get one of these,
and it's abnormal, often,
you go over there, and you
take a trip to the movies--
as my old teachers used to say--
and then you may find yourself
with an angioplasty or stent
or bypass.
So one of the sad
things about cardiology
is we don't define our
diseases by biology.
We define our
diseases often related
to whether the anatomy
of the physiology
is abnormal or normal, usually
based on some of these images
or some of these numbers.
OK.
So we have to make
decisions, and we often
use these very same
things too to be
able to make some decisions.
So we have to decide whether
we want to put a defibrillator,
and to do so, you often need
to get an echocardiogram
to look at the pumping
function of the heart.
If you want to decide on whether
somebody needs angioplasty,
you have to get an angiogram.
If you want to decided to
get a valve replacement,
you need an echo.
But some of these
other ones actually
don't involve any
imaging, and this
is sort of one of the
challenges that I'm
going to talk about is
that all of the future--
you can imagine building
brand new risk models,
new classification models.
You're stuck with the
data that's out there,
and the data that's
out there is ultimately
being collected because
somebody feels like it's worth
paying for it already.
So if you want to
build a brand new risk
model for who's going to
have a myocardial infarction,
you're probably not going to
have any echocardiograms to be
able to use for
that, because nobody
is going to have paid
for that to be collected
in the first place.
So this is a problem.
To be able to innovate, I've got
to keep on coming back to that,
because I think you're going to
be shocked by the small sample
sizes that we face in
some of these things.
And part of it is
because if you just
want to piggyback on
what insurers are going
to be willing to pay
for to get your data,
you're going to
be stuck with only
being able to work off
the stuff we already
know something about.
So much of my work
has been really trying
to think about how
we can change that.
OK, so just a little
bit more, and then we
can get into a
little bit more meat.
So sort of the
universal standard
for how imaging data is stored
is something called DICOMs,
or Digital Imaging and
Communications standard,
and really, the end
of the day, there
is some compressed
data for the images.
There's a DICOM header, which
I'll show you in a moment.
It's lots of nice
Python libraries
that are available to be
able to work with this data,
and there's a free
viewer you could use too.
OK.
So where do I get
access to this?
So this has actually
been an incredible pain.
So hospitals are set up
to be clinical operations.
They're not set
up to make it easy
for you to get gobs
of data for being
able to do machine learning.
It's just not really there.
And so sometimes, you have
some of these data archives
that store this
data, but there's
lots of reasons for why
people make that difficult.
And one of them is
because often images
have these burned in pixels
with identifiable information.
So you'll have a patient's
name emblazoned in the image.
You'll have date of birth.
You'll have kind of
other attributes.
So you're stuck
with that, and not
only is it a problem
that they're there,
the vendors don't make it
easy to be able to get rid
of that information.
So you actually have a
problem that they don't really
make it easy to download in
bulk or de-identify this.
And part of the reason
is because then it
would make it easy for you
to switch vendors and have
somebody else take over.
So they make it a
little bit hard for you.
Once it's in there, it's
hard for you to get it out,
and people are
selling their data.
That's certainly happening too.
So there's a little
bit of attempts
to try to control things that
way, and many of the labels
you want are stored separately.
So you want to know what the
diseases of these people.
So you have the
raw imaging data,
but all the clinical
stuff is somewhere else.
So you have to
sometimes link that,
and so you need to
get access there.
And so just to give you a
little bit of an idea of scale,
so we're about to get all the
ECGs from Brigham and Women's
which is about 30
million historically,
and this is all related to cost.
So positron emission tomography,
you can get about 8,000 or so,
and we're one of the
busiest centers for that.
Echocardiograms are in
the 300,000 to 500,000
range in archives.
So that gets a little
bit more interesting.
OK.
This is what a DICOM
header looks like.
You have some sort
of identifiers,
and then you have some
information there,
attributes of the
images, patient
name, date of birth, frame rate.
These kind of things are there,
and there's some variability.
So it's never quite easy.
OK.
So these different modalities
have some different benefits
to them which is
why they're used
for one disease or the other.
And so one of the real headaches
is that the heart moves.
So the chest wall moves,
because we breathe,
and the heart moves too.
So you have to
image something that
has enough temporal frequency
that you're not overwhelmed
by the basic movement
of the heart itself,
and so some of these
things aren't great.
So SPECT or PET
acquire their images,
which are radioactive
counts, over minutes.
So that's certainly
a problem when
it comes to something
that's moving like that,
and if you want to
have high resolution.
So typically, you have very
poor spatial resolution
for something that
ultimately doesn't deal well
with the moving aspect.
So coronary angiography has
very, very fast frame rates.
So that's X-ray, and
that's sort of very fast.
Echocardiography
can be quite fast.
MRI and CT are
not quite as good,
and so there's some
degradation of the image.
As a result, people do
something called gating,
where they'll take the
electrocardiogram, the ECG,
and try to line up
different portions
of different heartbeats.
And say, well, we'll take
this image from here,
line it up with this one
from there, this one--
I'm going to talk a little bit
about that, about registration,
but ultimately, that's a problem
that people have to deal with.
So it's a computer vision
problem of interest.
OK.
Preamble is almost done.
So why do we even
imagine any of this stuff
is going to be useful?
So it turns out that the
practice of interpreting
involves a lot of
manual measurements.
So people like
me, and people who
have trained for
way too long, find
themselves getting little rulers
and measuring various things.
So for example, this is
a narrowing of an artery.
So you could take a little
bit of calipers and measure
across that and
compare it to here
and say, ah, this
is 80% narrowed.
You could measure the
area of this chamber,
the left ventricle, and you
can measure its area is,
and you can see, ah,
its peak area is this.
It's minimum area is this.
Therefore, it's contracting
a certain amount.
So we do those things.
We measure those things by hand.
And the other thing we do is we
actually diagnose things just
by looking at them.
So this is a disease called
cardiac amyloid characterized
by some thickening.
I'll show you a little
bit more about that
and some sparkling here.
So people do look and say,
ah, this is what this is.
So there's kind of a
classification problem
that comes either at the
image or video level.
So we'll talk about whether
this is even worth doing.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
RAHUL DEO: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is this with
software, or do you literally
take a ruler and measure?
RAHUL DEO: So the software
involves clicking at one point,
stretching something, and
clicking another point.
So it's a little better
than pulling the ruler out
of your back pocket, but
not that much better.
OK.
So we're going to talk
about or three little areas,
and again, this is not--
I got involved in this really
in the last two years or so.
It's nice of David to
ask me to speak here,
but I think there
are probably people
in this room who have a lot
more experience in this space.
But the areas that have
been relevant to what we've
been doing has been image
classification and then
semantic segmentation.
So image classification being
assigning a label to an image,
very great.
Semantic segmentation, assigning
each pixel to a class label,
and we haven't done anything
around the image registration,
but there are some
interesting problems
I've been thinking about there.
And that's really mapping
different sets of images
onto one coordinate system.
OK.
So seems obvious that
image classification would
be something that you would
imagine a physician does,
and so maybe we can mimic that.
Seems like a reasonable
thing that happens.
So lots of things that
radiologists, people
who interpret images, do
involve terms of recognition,
and they're really fast.
So it takes them a couple of
minutes to often do things
like detect if there's
cancer, detect if somebody has
pneumonia, detect if there's
breast cancer in a mammogram,
tells there's
fluid in the heart,
and then even less than that,
one minute often, 30 seconds,
they can very, very fast.
So you can imagine
the wave of excitement
around image classification
was really post-image net,
so maybe about three years,
four years, or so ago.
We're always a little
slow in medicine,
so a little bit
behind other fields.
And the places that they
went were the places
where there are huge
data sets already,
and where there's simple
recognition tests.
So chest X-rays and
mammograms are both places
that had a lot of
attention, and other places
have been slowed down by just
how hard it is to get data.
So if you can't get a
big enough data set,
then you're not going
to be able to do much.
OK.
So David mentioned, you guys
already covered very nicely,
and this is probably
kind of old hat.
But I would say that prior to
convolutional neural networks,
nothing was happening in
the image classification
space in medicine.
It was just not.
People weren't even thinking
that it was even worth doing.
Now, there's a lot
of interest, and so I
have many different companies
coming and asking for help
with some of these things.
And so it is now a
very attractive thing
in terms of
thinking, and I think
people haven't thought
out all that well
how we're going to use that.
So for example, if it takes
a radiologist a minute
to two minutes to
read something,
how much benefit are you
going to get to automate it?
And the real
problem is you can't
take that radiologist away.
They're still there,
because they're
the ones who are on the hook.
And they're going to
get sued, and it's
among the most sued
profession in medicine.
So there's lots of people
who can read an X-ray.
You don't need to have
all that training.
But if you're the one
who's going to be sued,
it ends up being that
there really isn't
any task shifting in medicine.
There isn't that
kind of, oh, I'm
going to let such
and such take on 99%,
and just tell me when
there is a problem.
It just doesn't happen, because
they ultimately don't feel
comfortable passing that on.
So that's something
to think about.
So you have a task
that's relatively
easy for a very, very expensive
and skilled person to do,
and they refuse to give it up.
OK.
So that's a problem,
but you can imagine
there is some scenarios-- and
we'll talk more about this--
as to where that could be.
So let's say it's overnight.
The radiologist is sleeping
comfortably at home,
and you have a bunch
of studies being
done in the emergency room.
And you want to figure out,
OK, which one should we
call them about?
So you can imagine
there could be triage,
because the status quo would
be, we'll take them one by one.
Maybe you could imagine sifting
through them quickly and then
re-prioritizing them.
They'll still be looked at.
Every single one will
still be looked at.
It's just the order may change.
So that's an example,
and you could
imagine there could be
separate-- someone else could
read at the same time.
And we'll come back
to this in terms of
whether or not
you could have two
streams and whether or not
that is a scenario that
would make some sense.
And maybe, in
resource-poor settings,
where we're not teaming
with the radiologist,
maybe that makes sense too.
So we'll come back to that too.
OK.
So here's another problem.
So almost everything in
medicine requires some element
of confirmation of
a visual finding,
and some of the reasons
are very simple.
So let's say you want to talk
about there being a tumor.
So if you're going to ask
a surgeon to biopsy it,
you better tell
them where it is.
It's not enough to
just say, this image
has a tumor somewhere on it.
So there is some element
of that that you're
going to need to be a little
bit more detailed than simply
making a classification
with a level one image,
but I would say beyond that.
Let's say, I'm going to try
to get one of my patients
to go for valve surgery.
I'll sit with them,
bring up their echo,
sit side by side with them,
and point them to where it is.
Bring up a normal
one and compare,
because I want them to be
involved in the decision.
I want them to feel like
they're not just trust--
and they have to trust me.
At the end of the
day, they don't even
know that I'm showing--
I'll show them their name,
but ultimately, there
is some element of trust.
They're not able to do
this, but at the same time,
there is this sense of
shared decision making.
You're trying to communicate to
somebody, whose life is really
at risk here, that this is
why we're doing this decision.
So the more you could imagine
that there is obscuring,
the more difficult it
is to make that case.
So medicine is this--
I found this review by Bin Yu
from Berkeley, just came out,
and it talks about this tension
between predictive accuracy
and descriptive accuracy.
So this is of the typical thing
we think about that matters,
and there's lots
of people who've
written about this thing.
Medicine is tough in that it's
very demanding in this space
here, and it's almost
inflexible in this space here.
So it's a tough nut
to crack in terms
of being able to
make some progress,
and so we'll talk more about
when that's likely to happen.
OK.
So this again may be something
that's very familiar to you.
So we had this problem in
terms of some of the disease
detection models,
and I didn't find
this all that
satisfying in terms
being able to
successfully localize.
So just digging
through the literature,
it looks like this idea
of being able to explain
what part of the
image is driving
a certain classification.
That field is modestly old.
Maybe it goes back before that.
But ultimately,
there's two broad ways.
You can imagine finding an
exemplary image that maximally
activates the classical work,
or you can take a given image
and say, what aspect of it is
driving the classification?
And so in this paper here
did both those things.
They either went
through and optimized--
starting from an average
of all the training data--
they optimized the intensities
until they maximized
the score for a given class.
So that's what's shown here.
And then another way to do
it is in some sense you could
take a derivative of
the score function
relative to the intensities
of all the pixels
and come up with
something like this.
But you could imagine, if
you showed this to a patient,
they wouldn't be very satisfied.
So it's very difficult to make a
case that this is super useful,
but it seems like this field
has progressed somewhat,
and I haven't tried this out.
This is a paper by Max
Welling and company,
out by a couple of
years, and maybe you guys
are familiar with this.
But this ultimately is a little
bit of a different approach
in the sense that
they take patches,
the sort of
purple-like patch here,
and they compare the final
score, or class label,
relative to what it--
so taking the intensity
here and replacing it
by a conditional result
sampling from the periphery.
And just comparing
those two things
and seeing whether or not
you either get activation,
which is the red here.
This is the way that they
did the conditional sampling,
and then blue would be
the negative contributors.
And there, you can
imagine, there's
a little bit more
distinction here,
and then something a little
bit more on the medical side
is this is a brain MRI.
And so depending
on this patch size,
you get a different
degree of resolution
to localizing some areas of
the image that are relevant.
So this is something
that we're going
to expect a lot of demands
from the medical field in terms
of being able to show this.
And at least our
initial forays weren't
very satisfying doing this
with what we were doing,
but maybe these algorithms
have gotten better.
OK.
So next thing that matters.
So this is what people do.
So I did my cardiology
fellowship in MGH,
and I just traced circles.
That's what I did.
I just trace circles, and
I stretched a ruler across,
and then fed that in.
At least the program
computed the volumes
for me, the areas and
volumes, but otherwise, you
have to do this yourself.
And so this is like
a task that's done,
and sometimes you may have to--
here's an example of
volumes being computed
by tracing these sorts of things
and much radiology reports just
involve doing that.
So this seems like a
very obvious task we
should be able to improve on.
So medicine tends
to be not the most
creative in terms
of trying a bunch
of different architectures.
So if you look at the papers,
they all jump on the U-net
as being the
favorite architecture
for semantic segmentation.
So maybe familiar
to people here,
really, it just captures this
encoding or contracting layer.
Where you're downsampling,
and then there's
a symmetric upsampling
that takes place.
And then ultimately, there's
these skip connections, where
you take an image, and
then you can catonate it
with this upsampled layer, and
this helps get a little bit
more localization.
So we used this for
our paper, and we'll
talk about this a little
bit, and it's very popular
within the medical literature.
One of the things that
was quite annoying
is that what you would find
for some of the images,
you'd find, let's
say, a ventricle.
You'd find this
nicely segmented area,
and then you'd find this
little satellite ventricle
that the image would just pick.
The problem is that this
pixel-level classification
tends to be a
problem, and a human
would never make that mistake.
But that tends to be something
that sounds like it is common
in the-- this is a
common tension is
that this sort of focusing
on relatively limited scales
ends up being problematic,
when it comes to picking up
the global architecture.
And so there's lots
of different solutions
it looks like in the literature.
I just highlighted some
of these from a paper
that was published from
Google a little while ago.
One of the things
that's captured
is these ideas of
dilated convolutions,
and so that you
have convolutions
built on convolutions.
And so ultimately, you have
a much bigger receptive field
for this layer, though
you haven't really
increased the
number of parameters
that you have to learn.
So there is some.
It seems like there's lots.
This is not just
a problem for us
but a problem for many
people in this field.
So we need to be a little
bit more adventurous
in terms of trying some
of these other methods.
We did try a little bit of
that and didn't find a gains,
but I think,
ultimately, there still
needs to be a little
bit more work there.
OK.
So the last thing I'm
going to talk about
before getting into my
work is really this idea
of image registration.
So I talked about how there are
sometimes some techniques that
have limitations, either in
terms of spatial resolution
or temporal resolution.
So this is a PET scan here,
this sort of reddish glow here,
and in the background, we
have a CAT scan of the heart.
And so clearly, this is a
poorly registered image,
where you have the PET scan kind
of floating out here, when it
really should be lined up here.
And so you have something
that's registered better there.
I also mentioned this
problem but gating.
So ultimately, if you
have an image taken
from different
cardiac cycles, you're
going to have align
them in some way.
It seems like a very mature
problem in computer vision
world.
We haven't done
anything in this space,
but ultimately, it has
been around for decades.
If not, I would just at least
touch it, touch upon it.
So this is sort of
the old school way,
and then now people
are starting to use
conditional variational
autoencoders
to be able to learn
geometric transformations.
This is the Siemens group out in
Princeton that has this paper.
Again, nothing I'm
going to focus on, just
wanted to bring it up
as being an area that
remains of interest.
OK.
So I think we're doing
OK, but you said 4:00.
PROFESSOR: 3:55
RAHUL DEO: 3:55.
OK.
All right, and interrupt.
Please, interrupt.
OK?
I'm hoping that I'm
not talking too fast.
OK.
As David said, this
was not my field,
but increasingly,
there is some interest
in terms of getting
involved in it, in part
because of my frustrations
with clinical medicine.
So this is one of
my frustrations
with clinical medicine.
So cardiology has
not really changed,
and one of the things
it fails at miserably
is picking up
early-onset disease.
So here's the typical
profile, a little facetious.
So people like me
in our early 40s,
start to already
have some problems
with some of these numbers.
So I like to joke that, since I
came back to the Harvard system
from California, my blood
pressure has gone up
10 points which is
true, unfortunately.
So these changes
already start to happen,
and nobody does
anything about it.
So you can go to your doctor,
and you're also saying,
no, I don't want to
be on any medicine.
They're like, no, no, you
shouldn't be on any medicine.
So you kind hem and haw, and a
decade goes by, 15 years go by.
And then finally,
you're like, OK, well,
it looks like at
least my coworkers
are on some medicines, or maybe
I'll be willing to do that.
And so they've got lots of
stuff you can be treated,
but it is often very
difficult, and you see
this at the doctor level too.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: For the
optical values,
how much personal deviation
is there for the values?
RAHUL DEO: So the optimal
value is fixed and is just
like a reference value.
And you can be off--
so blood pressure, let's say.
So people consider optimal
to be less than 120
over less than 80.
People are in the 200s.
So you'd be treated in
the 200s, but there'll
be lots of people in
the 140s and the 150s,
and there'll be a degree
of kind of nihilism
about that for some time.
And my patients would be
like, oh, I got into the fight
with the parking attendant.
I just had a really bad phone--
there's like countless
excuses for why
it is that one shouldn't
start a medication,
and this can go on
for a long time.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
How can you assess the risk
[INAUDIBLE] for blood pressure?
Is that, like,
noise [INAUDIBLE]??
RAHUL DEO: Yeah.
So OK.
So that's a great point.
So yeah.
So the question is
that many of the things
that we're seeing
as risk factors have
inherent variability to them.
Blood sugar is another great
example of those things.
If you could have a
single-point estimate that
arises in the setting of
a single clinic visit,
how much do you trust that?
So it's a couple of
things related to that.
So one of them is
that people could
be sent home with monitors, and
they can have 24-hour monitors.
In Europe, that's much
more often done than here.
And then, the thing is that
often they'll say that,
and then you go look at
like six consecutive visits,
and they all have something
elevate, but it's true.
This is a noisy point
estimate, and people
have shown that averages
tend to do better.
But at the same time,
if that's all you have--
and the bias is interesting.
Because the bias comes
from some degree of stress,
but we have lots of
stress in our life.
I hopefully am not the
most stressful part
of my patient's life, and so
I think that ultimately there
are--
and the problem
with that is it's
a good reason for
someone to talk you out
of them starting
them on anything.
And that's what
ends up happening,
and so this can be a
really long period of time.
OK.
So this is the grim part.
OK?
So it turns out
that once symptoms
develop for something like
heart failure, decline is fast.
So 50% mortality in five
years, after somebody gets
hospitalized for their first
heart failure admission,
and often the symptoms
are just around that time.
So unfortunately,
these things tend
to be irreversible changes
that happen in the background,
and largely, you don't
really have any symptoms
until late in the game.
So we have this problem, where
we have this huge stretch.
We know that there
is risk factors,
but we have this huge stretch,
where nobody is doing anything
about them.
And then we have sort things
going downhill relatively
quickly after that.
And unfortunately,
I would make a case
that probably
responsiveness is probably
best did this phase over there.
Expense is really
all over there.
So we really want to find--
and this is what I consider
to be missing in medicine.
I'm going to come back to
this again a little bit later
on-- but really, we
want to have these--
if you're going to do something
in this asymptomatic phase,
it better be cheap.
You're not going to be
getting MRIs every day
or every year for people
who have no symptoms.
The system would
bankrupt if you had that.
So we need these
low cost metrics
that can tell us, at
an individual level,
not just if we had
1,000 people like you,
somebody would benefit.
And this is what
my patients would
say is that they would be
so excited about their EKG
or their echo being
done every year,
because they want to know,
how does it look like
compared to last year?
They want some comparison
at their level,
not just some
public health report
about this being a benefit
to 100 people like you.
And so it shouldn't
be both low cost,
should be reflective
at something
an individual level,
should be relatively
specific to the disease
process, expressive in some way,
and should get
better with therapy.
I think that's one
of the things that's
pretty important
is if somebody does
the things you ask
them to do, hopefully,
that will look better.
And then that would
be motivating,
and I think that's how
people get motivated is
that they get responses.
So I would make a case
that even simple things
like an ultrasound--
and I have one
showed here--
really does capture
some of these things,
and not all those things,
but they have some
of those things.
So you have, for example, that
in the setting of high blood
pressure, the left ventricular
mass starts to thicken,
and this is a quantitative,
continuous measure.
It just thickens over time,
and the heart starts to change.
The pumping function
can get worse over time.
The left atrium, which is
this structure over here,
this thin-walled structure
is amazing in the sense
that it's almost this barometer
for the pressure in the heart.
Oh, that's a horrible reference.
OK, but it tends to
get kind of bigger
and bigger in a very subtle
way before any symptoms happen.
So you have this, and
this is just one view.
Right?
So this is a simple
view acquired
from an ultrasound
that captures some
of these things at
an individual level.
So this gets to
some of my thoughts
around where we could imagine
automated interpretation
benefiting.
So if you want to think about
where you're less likely.
So with these very, very
difficult, end-stage,
or complex decisions,
where you have
a super skilled
person even collecting
the data in the first place.
They've gone through training.
They're super experienced.
You have a very expensive
piece of hardware
used to collect the data.
You have an expert
interpreting it.
This is done late in
the disease course.
You have to make
really hard decisions,
and you don't want
to mess it up.
So probably not
good places to try
to stick in an automated
system in there,
but what would be
attractive would
be to try to enable studies that
are not even being done at all.
So move to the
primary care setting.
Use low cost handhelds.
So there's even
now companies that
are starting to try to automate
acquisition of the data
by helping people
collect it and guide them
to collecting the right views.
Early in the disease course,
no real symptoms here.
Decision support just
around whether you
should start some meds or
intensify them, low liability,
low cost.
So this is a place
where we wanted
to focus in terms of
being able to introduce
some kind of innovations
in this space.
OK.
So this comes back
to this slide of I
talked about where you could
imagine some of these things
being low hanging fruit, but
maybe those aren't the ones
that we should be focusing
on we should instead
be focusing on enabling
more data at low cost,
getting more out of the
data that we're collecting,
and helping people even
acquire it in the first place.
So that's one category of
things, and that's the one
I just highlighted in
the previous slide.
You can imagine
something running
in the background at a
hospital system level
and just checking to see
whether there's anybody
who was missed in some ways.
And then triage I'm going to
talk about in the next slide.
I'll come back to that,
and then really-- and this
is, again, one of
the reasons I got
into this-- we want
to do something that
elevates practice beyond
just simply repeating
what we already do.
And so this idea of
quantitative tracking
of intermediate states,
subclasses of disease,
which is actually the real
reason I got into this space
is because I wanted to
increase scale of data
to be able to do this, and
this is where you potentially
would like to go.
So the ECG example is
an interesting one,
because automated systems
for ECG interpretation
have been around
for 40 or 50 years,
and they really got going
around the early 2000s, when
people realized--
there's a pattern
called an ST elevation.
I'm not sure if you
guys talked about that.
This is a marker of
complete stoppage
of blood flow to the heart.
So muscle starts to die.
And then the early 2000s, there
was a quality movement that
said, as soon as
anybody sees that, you
should get to somebody
doing something
about it within an
hour and a half or so.
And so the problem was that in
the old days and the old way
to do this--
and even this was
around the time
I was a resident--
you would have
to first call the cardiologist.
Wake him up.
They would come.
You'd send them the image.
They would look at it.
Then, they would
decide whether or not
this was the pattern
they were seeing,
and then they would activate
the lab, the cath lab.
They would come in, and you
were losing about an hour, hour
and a half in this process.
And so instead they decided
that automated systems could
be used to be able to
enable ambulance personnel
or emergency room docs,
so non-cardiologists,
to be able to say,
hey, look, this
is what we think is going on.
Let's bring the team in, and
so people would get mobilized.
People would come
to the hospital.
Nobody would do anything in
terms of starting the case,
until somebody confirmed it,
but already, the whole wheels
were turning.
And so you have
this triage system,
where you're making a decision.
You're not finalizing
the decision,
but you're speeding things up.
And so this is an
example where you
could imagine it's
important to try
to offload this to something.
So this is an
example, and there's
going to be false positives.
And people will laugh and mock
the emergency room doctors
and mock the ambulance
drivers and say, ah,
they don't know
what they're doing.
They don't have any experience.
But ultimately,
people were dying,
because they were waiting
for the cardiologist
to be available to read the ECG.
So you've got to think about
those in terms of places
where there may
be cost for delay.
OK.
So coming back to echoes.
So why does an echo get studied?
Because this is probably not
something that is typical.
It's a compilation
of videos, and there
are about 70 different videos
typically in the studies
that we do at the
centers that we're at.
And they're taken
over multiple cycles
and multiple different
views, and often it
takes somebody pretty skilled
to acquire those views.
And they take about
45 minutes to an hour
to gather that data,
multiple different views,
and the stenographer
is changing the depth
to zoom in on given structures.
And so you can understand
that there's already
somebody who was
already very experienced
in this process even collecting
the data which is a problem.
Because you need to take
them out of the picture,
because they're expensive to
be able to do those things.
So we were doing at
UCSF 12,000 to 50,000.
Brigham was probably a little
busier at 30,000 to 35,000.
Medicare back, in 2011, had
seven million of these perform,
and there's probably hundreds
of millions of these archives,
so lots of data.
So we published
a paper last year
trying to automate really all of
the main processes around this,
and part of the reason to do all
is it doesn't help you to have
one little bit automated.
Because at the end
of the day, if you
have to have a
cardiologist doing
everything else
and a stenographer
doing everything else,
what have you really saved
by having one little step?
So the goal here was to start
from raw study, coming straight
off the machine, and
try to do everything.
And so that involves
sorting through all
these different views, coming
up with empirical quality score
with it, segmenting all the
five primary views that we use.
Directly detecting
some diseases,
and then computing
all the standard mass
and volume types of measurements
that come from this.
So we wanted to do it all,
and this was, I think,
it wasn't strikingly original in
the algorithms that were used.
But at the same time, it
was very bold for anybody
in the community to try to
take this on, and of course,
in general, all the backlash
you could imagine when, you
try to do something like this.
I still hear it, but
there's excitement.
And certainly on
the industry side,
there's really excitement
in that this is feasible.
So I was running biology
lab, back in 2016 or so,
and then decided--
so my cousin's husband is the
Dean of Engineering at Penn,
and I emailed him and said, do
you know anyone at Berkeley?
I live near there.
I have a very long commute,
and I was like closer to there.
Is anybody you know there?
So he's like, yeah.
I know Ruzena Bajcsy there.
She used to be a Penn,
and I know Alyosha Efros.
And so he just emailed them
and said, can you meet?
[INAUDIBLE]
And so I met some
of them, and then I
tried to find some people
who were willing to work.
So I just spent a day a week
there for about two years,
just hanging out,
writing, code and try
to get this project
off the ground.
So we have a few
different institutions.
Jeff Zhang was a senior
undergraduate at the time.
He's at Illinois right
now as a graduate student.
It's interesting, because it's
hard to get grad student level
people excited over
stuff that's applications
of existing algorithms, but
they're happy to advise.
So I ended up having to write
a lot of the code myself.
And undergraduates
are, of course,
excited to do these
kind of things,
because it's better than
homework, and I can pay.
But I think, ultimately,
it's interesting to try
to find that sweet spot and
also find things that ultimately
could be interesting from an
algorithmic standpoint too.
So I'm trying to do
more of that these days.
OK.
So we aren't the first
to even do something
around classifying views.
So somebody already
had publish something,
but we wanted to be a little
bit more nuanced than that.
In that we wanted to
be able to distinguish,
for example, whether this
structure, the left ventricle,
is cut off.
Because we don't want to
measure it if it's cut off,
and we don't want to measure
the atrium if it's completely
cut off here.
So we wanted to be able
to have a classifier
able to distinguish between
some of those things.
It's not an easy task,
and a lot of these labels
were me riding the train in
my very long commute from East
Bay, in California, to UCSF.
And so I did a lot of labeling,
and I did a lot of segmentation
too.
So I could fly a lot.
And that's the
other thing that's
kind of interesting is
that you often need--
even to do the
grunt work-- you may
need somebody fairly specialized
to do it which is OK, but yeah,
so that ended up being
me for a lot of this.
So I traced a lot
of these images,
and then I got some
other people to help out.
But you're not going to get a
computer science undergraduate
to trace art structures
for you, nor are you
going to get them
excited about doing this.
So we didn't end up
having that much data,
and I think we could probably
get better than that.
But we had the five main views,
and we implemented a modified
version of unit algorithm.
We imposed a bit of
a penalty to keep
this problem of, for example,
a little stray ventricle
being out there.
We imposed a penalty
to say, well,
if that's too far away
from the center then,
we're going to have the
loss function take that
into account.
That helped somewhat, but so
that was our approach to--
this is a pretty
substantial deal
to be able to do all
these things that
normally would be very tedious.
And as a result, when we
start to analyze things,
we can segment every single
frame of every single video.
The typical echo reader will
take two frames and trace them.
That's it.
That's all you get.
So we can do everything over
every single cardiac cycle,
because there's amazing
variability from beat to beat.
And so it's silly
to think that that
should be the gold standard,
but that is the gold standard.
So we had thousands of echoes.
So that's the other thing.
So it turns out that it's
almost impossible to get access
to echoes, so I wrote a
keystroke encoder that
sat at the front end and just
mimicked me entering in studies
and downloading them.
So that was the only
way I could get.
So I had about 30,000
studies built up over a year,
but there's no way
to do bulk download.
And so again, you've got
to do some grunt work to be
willing to play this space.
So we had a fair
number of studies
we could use in
terms of where we
had measurements and decent
values in terms of that.
I think it's
interesting in terms
of thinking about how good one
can-- how close one can get.
And one of the things
we found is that,
when there were big deviations--
these are Bland-Altman plots--
almost always the
manual ones were wrong.
AUDIENCE: Why is that?
RAHUL DEO: Oh, OK.
OK.
So Bland-Altman plots, so people
don't like using correlations
in the medical--
so Bland and Altman published
a paper in the Lancet
about 30 years ago
complaining that correlations
and correlation coefficient are
ultimately not good metrics.
Because you could have
some substantial bias,
and really you want to know,
if this is the gold standard,
you need to get that value.
So it really is just
looking at differences
between, let's say, the
reference value and the,
let's say, automated
value, and then
plotting that against
the mean of the two.
So that's it.
I did it as percentages here,
but ultimately, it's just that.
It's that you're just
taking the mean of,
let's, say the left
ventricular volume.
You have a mean of the automated
versus the manually measured
one, and then you compare
what the difference is
of one minus the
other, and so you'll
be on one side or the other.
So ideally, you would just be
sitting perfectly on this line,
and then you're
going to look and see
whether or not you're clustered
on one side or the other.
So that's just
the typical thing.
People try to avoid
correlation coefficients,
because they kind of consider
them to be not really telling
you whether or not--
there really is a gold
standard, and there truly
is a value here, and you
want to be near that value.
And so that's the
standard for looking
at comparison of diagnostics.
So we had about 8,000 things.
The reviewers gave us a hard
time for the space up here,
and there are not that
many studies up here,
but ultimately, there are some.
And when we manually looked
at a bunch of them, always
the manual ones were just wrong.
Either there is a typo
or something like that,
so that was reassuring, but
we were sometimes very wrong.
And you'd find that the
places we'd be wrong
would be these ridiculously
complex congenital heart
studies that we had never
been given examples like that
before.
So that's a lesson to be learned
is that, sometimes, you're
going to be really off in
these sorts of approaches,
and you have to
think a little bit.
And what we ended
up doing is having
an interative cycle, where we
would identify those and feed
them back and of
keep on doing that,
but that still needs
to be improved upon.
OK.
So function, again, there's, a
couple of measures a function.
There's a company
that has something
out there in this
space, got FDA approved
for having an automated
ejection fraction.
So I think we're better
than their numbers,
overall, but yeah.
I think that that's just
one of those things you're
expected to be able to do.
And then here's a
problem that we run into.
So we're comparing to the
status quo which, like I said,
is one person tracing two
images and comparing them.
That's it.
So we're processing potentially
200, 300 different frames
per study and competing
median, smoothing across.
We're doing a whole
lot more than that.
So what do we do about that
in terms of the gold standard?
And if you just take into
observer variability,
you're going to
have up to 8% to 9%
in absolute compared to
60% of the reference.
So that's horrible.
So what are you supposed to do?
And I think so one
thing people do
is they take multiple readers
and ask them to do that.
But this is like,
are you're going
to get a bunch of
cardiologists to do
like 1,000 studies for you?
It's very hard to imagine
somebody doing that.
You could compare it
to another modality.
So we haven't done this yet,
but you could, for example,
compare it to MRI and
say whether or not
you're more consistent
with another modality.
And then this is
indirect, but you
can go to like
outcomes in a trial
and see whether or not
you do a better job.
So there are things you can do.
One of the things
we decided to do
is look for correlations
of structures
within a study itself
and say, well, the mass--
so we know that, for
example, thickened hearts
lead to larger
increases of pressure
and left atrial enlargement.
So we can look for correlations
between those things
and see whether we
do a better job.
I'd say, for, the most
part we're about on par
with everything that's there.
So I don't think
we're any better.
Sometimes we're better.
Sometimes we're worse.
And I think, for the most
part, this was another way
to try to get at this, because
we were stuck with this.
How do you work
with a gold standard
that ultimately I don't
think anybody really
trusts as a gold standard?
And this is a problem that
just has to keep on coming up.
This is just an
example of where you
could facilitate this idea
of low cost serial imaging
and point of care.
So these are patients who
are getting chemotherapy,
and so so Herceptin-- not
herception, Herceptin,
it's like inception--
is an EGFR inhibitor that
causes cardiac toxicity,
and so people are
getting screening echoes.
So you could imagine,
if you make it easier
to acquire and
interpret that, all
you want to care about is
the function and the size.
So you can imagine
automating that.
So we just did this
as proof of concept
that you could imagine
doing something like this.
And for the last thing
I want to talk about--
or sorry, the last
thing in this space--
is that you could also imagine
directly detecting disease.
And so you have to say, well,
why is that even worthwhile?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I was curious.
I guess it's going back
to the idea of if you look
at blended models
between human groud truth
and maybe a biological ground
truth, [INAUDIBLE] versus sort
of what you could get
from an MRI or something--
or maybe not necessarily an MRI,
but what you were saying based
on the underlying biology, or if
those two things are generally
kept separate?
RAHUL DEO: Yeah.
These are early days
for a lot of this,
and I think, anytime you make
anything more complicated,
then the readers will
give you a hard time,
but you can imagine that.
And especially, you
may want to tune things
to be able to be closer
to something like that.
So yeah, I think,
unfortunately, people
are pretty conservative in
terms of how they interpret,
but it does make some
sense that there's probably
something that--
Ideally, you want to be able to
have something that is useful,
and useful may not be exactly
the same thing as mimicking
what humans are doing.
So no, I think it's a good idea.
And I think that
this is going to be--
this next wave-- is going to
be thinking a little bit more
about that in terms
of like how do we
improve on what's going on
over there, rather than simply
dragging it back to that?
OK.
So there are multiple
rare diseases.
I use to have a clinic
that would focus on these,
and they tend to get
missed at centers
that don't see them that often.
So one place you
could imagine is
you can focus on trying
to pick those up,
and you could imagine, this
could be just surveillance
running in the background.
It doesn't have to be kind
of real time identification.
So there's a few
diseases where it's
very reasonable to
do these things,
where it's very obvious.
So this is a disease called
hypertrophic cardiomyopathy.
I used to see it in my clinic.
So abnormally thickened hearts,
leading cause of sudden death
in young athletes.
So Reggie Lewis, there's a bunch
of people who've died suddenly
from this condition.
Unstable heart rhythm,
sudden death, heart failure,
it runs in families,
and there are
things you can do,
if you identified it.
And so it's actually a fairly
easy task, in the sense
that it tends to
be quite obvious.
So we built the classification
model around this,
and we tried to understand
what it was doing in part.
And so we tried to do some
of these kind of attention
or saliency type things, and
they were very unsatisfying,
in part because I think there's
so many different features
across the whole image.
So you're just
getting this blob,
but I think maybe we just
weren't implementing it
correctly.
I'm not really sure, but you
have a left atrium gets bigger.
The heart gets thicker.
There's so many changes
across the image.
It was unsatisfying
in terms of that.
So we did something
simple and just
took the output of
the probabilities
and compared it to
some simple things
that we actually know
about these things
and found that there was
some degree of correlation.
But I would like to make
that a little bit better.
Cardiac amyloid, a very
popular disease for which
there are now therapies.
And so pharma is very interested
in identifying these people,
and they really get missed
at a pretty high rate.
So we built another
model for this.
Usually, we had about
250 or 300 cases
for each of these things and
maybe a few thousand controls.
And then this one's
a little interesting.
This is mitral valve prolapse.
So this is what a
prolapsing valve looks like.
If you imagine the plane of the
valve here, it buckles back.
So it does this,
and that's abnormal,
and this is a normal valve.
So you notice, it
doesn't buckle back in.
So it's a little interesting
in that there's really
only one part of the cardiac
cycle that would really
highlight this abnormality,
at least that's the way that--
so the way that
it's read clinically
is people wait for this one
part of the cardiac cycle
where it's buckled back.
They draw an
imaginary line across,
and they measure what the
displacement is there,
and so we built a
reasonable model focusing.
So we phased these
images and picked
the part of the cardiac
cycle, those relevant,
all in an automated
way and built a model
around that and pretty good, in
terms of being able to do that,
in terms of being
in detect that.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: And so is this model
on images at a certain time?
Like can you just go back?
Because obviously, you
weren't doing videos.
Right?
RAHUL DEO: Well, so we
would take the whole video.
We were segmenting it.
We were phasing it, figuring
out what the part of the--
when was the end
systole in that,
and then using those as the--
so using a stack of those
to be able to classify.
AUDIENCE: So how do you
know the time point?
RAHUL DEO: Well,
that's I'm saying.
So we we're using the
variation in the volumes.
AUDIENCE: The
segmentation would allow
you to know the time point.
RAHUL DEO: Exactly, because so
a typical echo will have an ECG
to use to gate, but
the handhelds don't.
So we want to move away
from the things that
involve the fanciness and
all the bells and whistles.
We're trying to
use the image alone
to be able to tell
the cardiac cycle.
So that's how we did it.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned handhelds.
With the ultrasounds
[INAUDIBLE],,
are they different from these?
RAHUL DEO: They
look pretty similar.
We got some now, and
they look pretty similar
in terms of the
quality of the images,
and you can acquire
the very same view.
So I think we haven't shown that
we can do it off those, in part
because there just isn't
enough training data.
But they look pretty
nice, and I know at UCSF
and at Brigham, all the
fellows are using it.
It looks pretty much the same in
terms of the-- the transducers
are similar, and image
quality is very good.
Resolution is very good.
Frame rate probably doesn't
get up as high necessarily,
but for the most part, I don't
think it's that different.
So that is the next phase.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Could you comment on--
so you mentioned how each
of these three examples
could be used within a
surveillance algorithm.
RAHUL DEO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could you
comment on where
along this true positive,
false positive trade-off
you would actually be
realistic to use this?
RAHUL DEO: Yeah.
That's a good point.
I think it would vary for
every single one of those,
and you really want to have
some costs on what the--
so I would typically err on
the side of higher sensitivity
and dump it on the
cardiologists to be able to--
so I would work, but I think
you have to pick some--
let's say, you're
a product manager.
AUDIENCE: Just choose one
of these three, and maybe--
RAHUL DEO: OK.
Yeah.
So this is a pretty
rare disease.
So your priors are pretty low
in terms of these individuals.
And so I think you
probably would probably
want to err somewhere
along this area here,
and so just working
on what the--
so you probably will still
be a relatively high rate
of false positives
even that space.
But I would argue that it would
take the treating cardiologist
potentially just a few minutes
to look at that study again,
and if you picked up one
of those patients, that
would be a big win.
So I think that the cost
probably wouldn't be that high,
and you just have
to make the case.
So therapy for
amyloid, for example,
this is a nice sharp
up stroke there.
There's new drugs
out there that are
sort of begging for
patients, and they're
having a real hard
time identifying them.
So you could imagine
again, it's sort
of a calculus based on
what the benefits would
be for that identification
and what burden you're
placing on the individuals to
have to over read something.
And you could probably
tune that depending
on what the disease is and
who you're pitching it to.
But you're right, you're
going to crush people
if like 1 in 100 ends up
taking a true positive then
you're not going
to get many fans.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Could you comment
on whether, for example,
[INAUDIBLE] basis,
the ones that you're
able to predict very
well at that point
you just chose what
distinguishes the ones that
are defined well?
RAHUL DEO: So
that's a good point,
and I don't really
know in the sense
that I haven't
looked that closely.
But I'm going to guess, they're
very thick and very obvious
in that sort of sense.
So we have a ECG model that
may pick this up early.
What you want is
something to fix it up
when it's treatable, not
having something that's
ridiculously exaggerated.
So you may need multiple
modalities some of which
are more sensitive than others
that can catch earlier stage
disease to be able to do that.
So there are interesting
things about this disease
in particular.
So cataracts sometimes
happen before--
so ideally, the way you do
this is-- and I'm actually
consulting around
something like this--
you ideally want a mixture
of electronic health record,
something from other findings--
mirror findings, eye findings,
plus maybe something
cardiac plus
and have something
that ideally catches
the disease in the ideal
most treated state.
And maybe echo's
not the best one,
and I think that we'll come
back to that at the end.
We have a little bit of time.
OK.
So UCSF is filing--
I don't know.
I don't think this is
actually patentable,
but they are filing
for a patent.
I'm just filling the paperwork
out today in terms of--
I don't know.
But my code is all
freely available anyway,
for academic, non-profit
use, and they're just
trying to make it better.
I think, ultimately, my
view as an academic here is
to try to show what's possible.
And then, if you want to
get a commercial product,
then you need people to
weigh in on the industry side
and make something pretty and
make it usable and all that.
But I think,
ultimately, I'm trying
to just show, hey, if we could
do this in a scalable way
and find out something
new, then you guys
can catch up and
do something that
ultimately can be deployed.
And what's interesting is I have
a collaborator in New Zealand.
There, they're
are resource poor.
So they have a huge
backlog of patients.
They don't have
enough stenographers,
and they don't have
enough cardiologists.
So they're trying to
implement this super ultra
quick five-minute study
and then have automation.
And so they want our accuracy
to be a little bit better,
but I think they're
ready to roll out,
if we're able to get something
that has probably more training
data.
Yes.
Are you from New Zealand?
AUDIENCE: No.
I think you started talking
about the trade-off between
accuracy and--
so in academia, I get the
sense that they're always
chasing perfect accuracy.
RAHUL DEO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But as
you said, you're
not going to get rid of
cardiologists in the diagnosis.
So I have a
philosophical question
of are you chasing
the wrong thing?
Should we chase
perfect accuracy?
RAHUL DEO: Yeah.
So the question is around
what should our goals be?
So should we be just chasing
after a level of accuracy
that may be either very,
very difficult to attain?
And especially, if there's never
a scenario where there'll be
no clinician involved,
should we instead
be thinking about
something that gets good
enough to that next step?
And I think that's
a really good point.
And what's interesting is--
and also it's interesting
from the industry side--
is the field starts
with the mimicking mode,
because it's much harder
to change practice.
It's much easier to just pop
something in and say, hey,
I know you have to make
these measurements.
Let me make them for you,
and you could look at them
and see if you agree.
So that's what ECGs do.
Right?
So nobody these days is
measuring the QR rests width.
Nobody does that.
That's just not done.
If you've got a number that's
absurd, you'll change it.
But for the most part, you're
like, it's close enough,
but you almost have
to start with that.
To do something
that's transformative
is very hard to do.
So I think something
that involves--
and I talked to
David about this.
It's sort of like the
man-machine interface is
fascinating to think
about how do we together
come up with something better?
But it's just much harder to
get that adopted, because it
requires buy-in in a way
that's different than just
you do my work for me, but
more that we come together
to do something better.
And I think that's going
to be interesting as to how
to chip away at that problem.
OK.
So a couple of
musings, then I'm going
to talk a little bit about One
Brave Idea, if we have time,
or I can stop and take
questions instead,
because it's a little
bit of a biology venture.
OK.
So I do think that we
should really look.
People give me a hard time
around echo, and I'm like,
well, ECG's been
around for a long time,
and there's automation there.
So let's think about
how it's used there,
and then see whether or not--
it's not as outlandish
as people think.
So I think a lot of these
routine measurements
are just going to be
done in an automated way.
Already in our software, you
can put out a little picture
and overlay the segmentation
on the original image
and say how good it looks.
So that's easy.
So you can do that.
And then this kind of idea
of point of care automated
diagnoses can make
some sense around
some emergency-type situations.
So maybe you need a
quick check of function.
Maybe you want to
know if they have
a lot of fluid around the
heart, and you don't necessarily
want to wait.
So those will be
the places where
there may be some
kind of innovations
around just getting
something done quickly.
And then you always
have somebody checking
in the background,
layer on, a little
the heart attack
thing I showed you,
and I think this problem
in echo is there.
And so if you need
skilled people
to be able to acquire the
data in the first place,
you're stuck, because
they can read an echo.
A really good stenography can
read the whole study for you.
So if you already have
that person involved
in the pipeline,
then it's really hard
to introduce a big advance.
So you need to figure out
how to take a primary care
doc off the street, put
a machine in their hand,
and let them get the image
and then automate all
the interpretation for them.
And so until you can task
shift into that space,
you're stuck with having still
too high a level of skill.
So there are these companies
that are in the space now,
and there's a few
that are trying.
It's easy to imagine, if you
can train a neural network
to classify a view,
you could get it to--
this gets to this
idea of registration
a little bit-- you can recognize
if you're off by 10 degrees,
or if you need a translation.
You could just train a
model to be able to do that.
So I think that's already
happening right now.
So it's a question as to whether
that will get adopted or not,
but I think that,
ultimately, if you
want to get shifting towards
sort of less skilled personnel,
you need to do
something in that space.
OK.
So this is where it
gets a little bit harder
is to think about how to make
stuff and elevate medicine
beyond what we're doing.
And this gets back
to this problem
I mentioned is, at
the end of the day,
you can't find
new uses for echo,
unless the data is
already there for you
to be able to show
that there's more value
than there currently is, sort
of this chicken and egg thing.
So in some sense, what I
hope to introduce in some way
that we can get much
bigger data sets,
and they don't have to
be 100 video data sets.
They can be three
video data sets,
but we want to be
able to figure out
how to enable more and
more of these studies.
So then you can sort
of imagine learning
many more complicated things.
You want to track
people over time.
You want to look at
treatment responses.
So you've got to look at
where the money is already
and see who could do this.
So pharma companies
are interested,
because they have
these phase II trials.
They may only have three
months or six months
to show some benefit
for a drug, and they're
really interested in
seeing whether there's
differences after a month,
two months, three months, four
months.
So that may be a
place where you get--
and they're being frugal,
but they have money.
So you could
imagine, if you could
introduce this pipeline in there
and just have handheld, simple,
quick to acquire, far
more frequency, and you
show a treatment response, and
that's kind of transformative
then.
Because then, you
could imagine, that
can get rolled out in
practice after that.
So you need somebody to
bankroll this to start with,
and then you could imagine,
once you have a use case,
then you could imagine
it getting much more.
And this idea of
surveillance, you
could imagine that would be
very doable, that you could just
have something taking--
The problem is, you can even
get the data in the archives
anyway, but let's
say you can get that.
You could just have this
system looking for amyloid,
looking for whatever,
and that would be a win
too is to be able to imagine
doing something like that.
It's not putting any pressure
on the clinical workflow.
It's not making
anybody look bad.
I think, ultimately, it's
trying to just figure out if--
well, maybe somebody
may be looking bad
if they miss
something, but yeah.
I think it is just trying
to identify individuals.
And so this is an area
I think that's hard,
and so this kind
of idea, this is
where I started a little
bit, around this kind of idea
of this disease
subclassification and risk
models.
And so that's like more
sophisticated than anything
we're doing.
I think we're pretty crude
at this kind of stuff,
but one of the
challenges is people just
aren't interested in new
categories or new risk models,
if they don't have some way
that they can change practice.
And that becomes more
difficult, because then you
need to not only
introduce the model,
you need to show
how incorporating
that model in some way is
able to either identify
people who respond.
It always comes
down to therapies
at the end of the day.
So can you tell me some subclass
of people who will do better
on this drug, which
means that you
have to have trial data that
has all those people with all
that data.
And unfortunately, because
echoes are so expensive
and places like the Brigham
charge like $3,000 per echo,
then you only have
like 100 people
who have an echo in a trial
or 300 people have an echo.
You have a 5,000 person trial,
and 5% of them have an echo.
So you need to change the way
that gets done, because you're
massively underpowered to be
able to detect anything that's
sort of a subgroup
within that kind of work.
So yeah, unfortunately,
the research pace of things
outpaces the change in
practice in terms of the space,
until we're able to enable
more data collection.
So I can stop there.
I was going to talk about
blood cells in slides.
PROFESSOR: We can
take some questions.
RAHUL DEO: Yeah.
Yeah.
OK.
Why don't we do that.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: When CT
reconstruction started,
I remember seeing some papers
where people said, well,
we know roughly what to the
anatomy should look like,
and so we can fill
in missing details.
In those days, the
slices were run before,
and so they would hallucinate
what the structure looked like.
RAHUL DEO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And of course, that
has the benefit of giving you
a better model, but
it also does risk
that it's hallucinated data.
Have you guys tried doing
that with some of the--
RAHUL DEO: Yeah.
That's a great point.
So OK.
So the question was
so cardiac imaging has
a very long history, and so
there was a period of time
where there's these
kind of active modelers
around morphologies
of the heart.
And so people had these
models around what
the heart should look like
from many, many, many studies.
And they were using that,
back at the time, when
you had these relatively coarse
multi-slice scanners for a CT,
they would reconstruct
the 3D image of the heart
based on some pre-existing
geometric model for what
the heart should look like.
And there's, of course,
a benefit to that,
but some risk in the
sense that somebody
may be very different in
the space that's missing.
And so the question is
whether those kind of priors
can be introduced
in some way, and it
hasn't been straightforward
as to how to do that.
Whenever you look at
these ridiculously poor
segmentations, you're
like, this is idiotic.
We should be able to
introduce some of that,
and I've seen people, for
example, put an autoencoder.
That's not exactly
getting at it,
but it's actually
getting it somewhat
with these coarser features.
But no, I think
in terms of using
some degree of
geometric priors, I
think I may have seen some
literature in that space.
We haven't tried anything there.
We don't have any data to
do that, unfortunately,
and I suspect,
yeah, I just don't
know how difficult that is.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
that you don't
want to see a small additional
atrium off at a distance.
So that's, in a way,
building in knowledge.
RAHUL DEO: Yeah.
No.
I remember when I was
starting this space.
I was like this is idiotic.
Why can't we do this?
Why don't we have some
way of doing that?
We couldn't find at that
time any architectures that
were straightforward
to be able to do that,
but I'm sure there is
something in that space.
And we didn't also have the
data for those priors ourselves.
There's a long history of
these de novo heart modelers
that exist out there from
Oxford and the New Zealand
group for that
matter who've been
doing some of this kind
of multi-scale modeling.
It will be interesting
to see whether or not
there is anybody who pushes
forward in that space,
or is it just more data?
I think that's
always that tension.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask
about ultrasounds?
RAHUL DEO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You didn't
show us ultrasounds.
Right?
RAHUL DEO: Yeah, I did.
AUDIENCE: Oh, you did?
RAHUL DEO: Yeah.
The echoes are ultrasounds.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK, but that's
really expensive ultrasound.
Right?
Like there are
cheaper ultrasounds
that you could imagine
that you constantly do.
Right?
RAHUL DEO: Yeah.
So there is a company
that just came out
with the $2,000 handheld
ultrasound, the subscription
model.
Yeah.
So I think that Philips
has a handheld device
around the $8,000 marker, so
$2,000 is getting quite cheap.
So that's I think the
space for handheld devices.
AUDIENCE: We're talking about
resource-poor countries.
RAHUL DEO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: In a developing
country, where maybe they
have very few doctors per
population kind of thing.
What kind of imaging
might be useful
that we could then apply
computer vision algorithms to?
RAHUL DEO: I think ultrasound
is that sweet spot.
It has versatility, and
its cost is about where--
and I'm sure those
companies rented it out
for much lower cost in
those kinds of places too.
We're putting together-- or
I put together-- actually,
it may not have been funded.
I'm not sure.
But looking at
sub-Saharan Africa
and collaborating with
one of the Brigham doctors
who travels out to
sub-Saharan Africa
and looking to try to build some
of these automated detection
type of things in that space.
So no, I think there is
definite interest in that,
and then there may be a much
bigger win there then the stuff
I'm proposing.
But yeah, no, I think
that's a very good point,
and that would be--
it's also, it's portable.
You could have a
phone-based thing.
So it's actually very
attractive from that standpoint.
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
RAHUL DEO: All right.
I feel like I'm changing the
topic substantially but not
totally.
OK.
So this is that slide I showed,
and I pitched it in a way
to try to motivate you
to think of ultrasound.
But I'm not sure
ultrasound really
achieves all these things, in
the sense I wouldn't call it
the greatest biological tool
to get at underlying disease
pathways.
Some of these things may
be late, like David said,
or maybe not so reversible.
So we've been given this One
Brave Idea thing $85 million
now to make some dent in
a specific disease, so
coronary artery disease
or coronary heart disease.
It's that arrogant
tech thing, where
you just dump a lot
of money somewhere
and think you're going
to solve all problems.
And happy to take
it, but I think
that there are some problems.
So this is what I
wanted to do, so I've
wanted to do this for
probably the last five, six
years, before I
even started here,
and this has motivated me
in part for quite a while.
And so here's our problems.
OK.
So we're studying heart disease,
so coronary artery disease
or coronary heart disease is
the arteries in the heart.
You can't get at those.
So you can't do any biology.
You can't do the stuff
the cancer people-- do
you can biopsy that.
You can't do anything there.
So you're stuck with
the thing that you
want to get at is inaccessible.
I talked about how a lot of
the imaging is expensive,
but all those other omic
stuff is really expensive too.
So that's going to
be not so possible,
and you're not going to be able
to do serial $1,000 proteomics
on people either.
That's not happening
anytime soon.
And then everything I talked
about, we were woefully
inadequate in terms
of sample size,
especially if we
want to characterize
underlying complex
biological processes.
So we expect we're going to
need high dimensional data,
and we're going to
need huge sample sizes.
There's Vladimir
Vapnik over there.
And then here's another problem.
OK?
So this stuff takes time.
These diseases take time.
So if I introduce a
new assay right now,
how am I going to
show that any of this
is going to be beneficial?
Because this disease
develops or 10 to 20 years.
So I'm not going to talk
about the solution to that,
well, a little bit.
OK.
So one of the issues with
a lot of the data that's
out there is it's not
particularly expressive.
It's a lot of that just
the same clinical stuff,
the same imaging stuff.
So all these big studies, these
billion dollar big studies,
ultimately just have
echoes and MRIs and maybe
a little bit of
genetics, but they really
don't have stuff
that is this low cost
expressive biological
stuff that we ideally
want to be able to do.
So this is really expensive
and makes $85 million look
like a joke, and
it's not all that
rich in terms of complexity.
So we wanted to do
something different,
and so this is the crazy thing.
We're focusing on
circulating cells,
and so this is a compromise.
And there's a
reasonably good case
to be made for
their involvement.
So there's lots
of data to suggest
that these are causal mediators
of coronary artery disease
or coronary heart disease.
So you can find
them in the plaques.
So patients who have
autoimmune diseases
certainly have accelerated
forms after atherosclerosis.
There are drugs.
There's a drug
called canakinumab
that inhibits IL-1 one beta
secretion from macrophages,
and this has mortality benefit
in coronary artery disease.
There are mutations in
the white blood cell
population themselves that are
associated with early heart
attack.
So there's a lot there,
and this has been going--
and there's plenty
of mouse models
that show that if
you make mutations
only in the white
blood cell compartment,
that you will completely change
that the disease course itself.
So there's a good
amount of data out there
to suggest that there is an
informative kind of cell type
there.
It's accessible.
There's lots of
predictive models
already there that could
be done with some of this,
and they express many of
the genes that are involved.
And there's a window on many
of these biological processes.
So we're focusing on computer
vision approaches to this data.
So we decided, if we
can't do the omic stuff,
because it costs too
much, we're going
to take slides and
have tens of thousands
of cells per individual.
And then we can introduce
fluorescent dyes
that can focus on lots
of different organelles.
And then we can potentially
expand the phenotypic space
by adding all kinds
of perturbations
that can be able to
unmask attributes
of people that may not even be
relatively there at baseline.
And I think I've been empowered
by the computer vision
experience with the echo
stuff, and I'm like, hey,
I can do this.
I can train these models.
So we're in a position
now where we can--
this stuff costs a few
dollars per person.
It's cheap, and
you can just keep
on expanding phenotypic space.
You can bring in drugs.
You can bring in
whatever you want here,
and you're still in
that dollars type range.
So we just piggy-back,
and we just hover around--
just a couple of
research assistants
were hovering around clinics.
And we can do
thousands of patients
a month, so tens of
thousands of patients a year.
So we can get into a deep
learning sample size here,
and so we want
these primary assays
to be low cost,
reproducible, expressive,
ideally responsive to therapy.
So that's this space here,
and there's lots of stuff
that we have.
We have all the medical record
data on all these people,
and we can selectively
do somatic sequencing.
We can do genome associations.
We have all ECG data.
We have selective
positron emission data.
So it's lots of
additional thought,
and we want to be able
to walk our cheap assay
towards those things
are more expensive
but for which there's
much more historical data.
So that's what I do
with my life these days,
and the time problem
has been solved.
Because we found a collaborary
MGH who has 3 1/2 million
of these records in terms of
cell counting and cytometer
data going back for
about three years.
So we should be able to get
some decent events in that time.
I need to build a document
classification model for 3 1/2
million records and decide
whether they have coronary
heart disease, but sounds
like that's doable.
We're fearless in this space.
And then they also
have 13 million images,
so hundreds of thousands
of people worth of slides.
So we can at the very
least, get decent weights
for transfer learning
from some of this data,
and we're doing this for
acute heart attack patients.
So yeah, so this is what
I'm doing, ultimately,
and so it's this bridge between
existing imaging, existing
conventional medical
data, and this low cost,
expressive, serial-type
of stuff that ultimately
hoping to expand phenotypic
space and keep the cost down.
I think all my lessons from
working with expensive imaging
data has motivated me to build
something around this space.
So this is my it's
my baby right now.
And so lots of things for
people to be involved in,
if they want to, and these are
some of the funding sources.
All right.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]